apocalyptic battle scenes are front and
center in eastern Ukraine near buckmut
Frank is trying to reclaim land from
Russian forces but it is a Monumental
task letting the war drag on is a huge
mistake
U.S businessman and philanthropist
Howard Buffett has spent Millions
helping injured Ukrainian soldiers but
fears the West has War fatigue allies
know it and are trying to combat it
Ukraine is not asked any other country
to fight for them
all they're asking for is help help long
term is reaffirmed by those supporting
Ukraine including Canada before
attending a meeting in Germany defense
minister Bill Blair met with Canadian
Armed Forces members training ukrainians
in the UK Blair says Canadians
understand what is at stake and that
Canada has more to offer much more work
needs to be done and those announcements
will be coming in the coming weeks
Ukraine's front line reportedly
stretches over 1 000 kilometers
roughly the driving distance from
Vancouver to Banff we're supposed
Ivan says his biggest fear is the
Russians will reach his hometown of
thought interrupted
by an explosion Russia is not just
defending what it has taken from Ukraine
but is pushing for more
military experts say strikes on enemy
Supply chains can be useful to buy time
and disrupt strategic plants an oil
Depot in Sochi was hit by a drone strike
early Wednesday the latest Russian site
to be targeted Ukraine has not claimed
responsibility Crystal commencing Global
News London